Das ist eine ziemlich genaue
Darstellung davon, wie Anthropic diese
Seitenhiebe von OpenAI aufnimmt, ohne
sie tatsächlich zu beeinträchtigen,
da Anthropic nach all den Problemen,
mit denen sie als Unternehmen in den
letzten Monaten von den Problemen mit
der Ratenbegrenzung bis zur
Unterleistung ihrer Modelle
konfrontiert waren, ein ernsthaftes
Comeback hingelegt hat. Sie sind
endlich mit vielen konkurrenzfähigen
Modellen zurück, aber wir haben sogar
noch ein weiteres verrücktes Modell
von Anthropic in der Pipeline. Und das
ist Fable 5.5, das früher erscheinen
könnte, als die meisten Leute erwarten
. In Anbetracht der Sprünge, die wir
von der 5.0 er-Modellreihe zur 5.5
er-Reihe gesehen haben, könnte das
enorm sein. Ich habe auch das neue
Modell, das sie heute vorgestellt haben
, nämlich Sonnet 5.5, ausgiebig
getestet, und ehrlich gesagt könnte es
für viele Leute zum täglichen
Begleiter werden. Es ist günstiger,
schneller und war in meinen Tests
extrem konkurrenzfähig mit GPT 6 Soul
und in vielen Fällen sogar besser. Und
ich habe auch Fälle gesehen, in denen
es Opus 5.5 aussticht, aber günstiger
ist. Schaut euch das mal an. Das
günstigste mittelgroße Modell von
Anthropic ist hier draußen und
erstellt vollwertige Fortnite-Klone.
Das ist nicht nur einer der Fälle, in
denen dieses Modell Opus 5.5
ausgestochen hat. Das hat es schon oft
in vielen verschiedenen
Domänenaufgaben getan. Das alles wurde
mit dem 20-Dollar-Pro-Tarif
durchgeführt und das ist nur die
Spitze des Eisbergs, denn ich habe noch
viele weitere Tests, die ich im Laufe
des heutigen Videos vorstellen werde.
Leute, das alles muss OpenAI etwas
unter Druck setzen, denn der DevDay
steht quasi vor der Tür. Wir hatten
ursprünglich darüber gesprochen, dass
OpenAI am DevDay ein neues Modell
veröffentlichen wird. Es gab sogar
Gerüchte über die Veröffentlichung
von GPT 6.1, aber heute haben wir dazu
einige Neuigkeiten. Möglicherweise
handelt es sich dabei um ein Modell,
das jetzt verzögert wurde. Laut Wall
Street Journal wurde es aus
Sicherheitsgründen verzögert, könnte
man sagen. Aber ich weiß aus meiner
eigenen Erfahrung mit globalen Medien,
wie das Mediengewerbe tatsächlich
läuft. Manchmal arbeiten Unternehmen
direkt mit großen Medien zusammen, um
zu gestalten, wie Ankündigungen und
Verzögerungen kommuniziert werden. Ich
sage nicht, dass es hier bestätigt ist
, aber man kann die Punkte
offensichtlich verbinden. Eine
sicherheitsrelevante Verzögerung gibt
OpenAI auch mehr Zeit, an dem Modell zu
arbeiten, ohne dass die Verzögerung zu
negativen Gefühlen führt. Wie auch
immer, der Dev Day kommt und es gibt
eine Menge zu besprechen. Wir werden
über einige der neuen Leaks sprechen,
die vom Dev Day aufgetaucht sind, und
über einige der neuen Dinge, die sie
auf den Markt bringen werden, wie die
Cerebrus-Infrastruktur sowie den O
Assistant. Und auch in den chinesischen
Laboren wird hinter den Kulissen
gekocht. Wir sehen endlich die ersten
Ergebnisse der Clan 4.0-Reihe. Kimmy K
3.1 könnte möglicherweise um den
Nationalfeiertag herum erscheinen, der
in wenigen Tagen am 1. Oktober ist, und
Deep Seek Version 4.1 Pro scheint
ebenfalls näher zu rücken. Und bevor
wir überhaupt ins Detail gehen, würde
es mir wirklich die Welt bedeuten, wenn
ihr dieses Video liken und mich
abonnieren könntet. Da mir das
wirklich hilft, Videos für euch zu
machen, und es mir einfach die Welt
bedeuten würde, weil ich mein Bestes
gebe, um diese neuen Ziele zu erreichen
, würde es mir wirklich sehr viel
bedeuten, wenn ihr das einfach tun
könntet. Aber mit diesem Gedanken
lasst uns einfach direkt in das heutige
Video eintauchen. Zahlt ihr immer noch
lieber für das Scraping von Websites,
anstatt eure KI dafür zu bezahlen,
diesen Müll zu lesen? Nun, der heutige
Sponsor, Tiny Fish, möchte das ändern
. Im 45-seitigen Benchmark von Tiny
Fish waren die typischen
Fire-Crawl-Ergebnisse etwa 38%Müll,
Menüs, Cookie-Leisten und Werbung. Ihr
habt dafür bezahlt, diese Inhalte zu
scrappen, und zahlt erneut in Token,
wenn ihr das Modell zum Lesen benötigt
. Tiny Fish macht die Suche und den
Abruf in jedem Tarif kostenlos, mit
saubereren Inhalten für eure KI. Und
schickt Tiny Fish jetzt die neueste
Firecrawl-Rechnung, und sie werden euch
den entsprechenden Betrag in euren
Wallet-Guthaben gutschreiben. Diese
Guthaben treiben den Web-Agenten und
den Browser an. Automatisiert
Anmeldungen, navigiert durch Websites,
füllt Formulare aus und erhaltet
strukturierte Daten zurück. Oder
führe deine eigenen
Cloud-Browser-Workflows aus. Die Suche
und der Abruf bleiben auch nach
Aufbrauchen deines Guthabens kostenlos.
Keine Kreditkarten erforderlich.
Firecrawl muss nicht gekündigt werden.
Klicke auf die Links in der
Beschreibung unten, um dir dein
Guthaben zu sichern. Das Angebot endet
am 16. Oktober. Und vielen Dank an
Tinybird für das Sponsoring des
heutigen Videos. Fangen wir mit dem
Giganten an, nämlich Fable 5.5. Denn
Leute, dieses Modell wird der Wahnsinn.
Ich habe einiges zu diesem Modell
gesehen, und wenn das so ist, wie es
aussieht, und wenn es sich bestätigt,
könnte das etwas ganz anderes werden.
Genau deshalb wollte ich über Fable
sprechen, bevor wir uns Sonnet 5.5
widmen. Im Moment sieht es so aus, als
könnte OpenAI in den nächsten Wochen
einen harten Kampf bevorstehen, denn
Gerüchten zufolge soll Fable 5.5
früher erscheinen, als die meisten
erwarten. Und sieh dir nur die
Fortschritte an, die Anthropic bereits
in der 5.5-Familie gemacht hat. Sonnet
5.5 ist deutlich besser als Sonnet 5
und selbst Haiku 5.5 könnte weit über
seiner Gewichtsklasse liegen und es
sogar mit Soul aufnehmen. Anthropic hat
bereits bestätigt, dass Haiku 5.5 in
den nächsten Wochen erscheinen wird.
Stellen Sie sich also vor, was passiert
, wenn Anthropic diese Verbesserungen
übernimmt und sie auf Fable, sein
absolutes Pioniermodell, anwendet. Der
einzige Bereich, in dem OpenAI noch
einen großen Vorteil haben könnte,
ist die Token-Effizienz. Und das wird
eine große Rolle spielen, wenn es um
diese Modelle geht, die lange
Agentenaufgaben ausführen. Aber da GPT
-6.1 Astra Berichten zufolge wegen
Nichterfüllung der Sicherheits-und
Ausrichtungsanforderungen von OpenAI
auf Eis gelegt wurde, ist die größte
Frage, was OpenAI als Nächstes tut.
Treiben sie die aktuelle Generation mit
mehr RL weiter voran oder kommen wir an
einen Punkt, an dem sie die nächste
Generation von Pre-Train auf den Markt
bringen müssen, um im Grunde genommen
auf das zu reagieren, was Anthropic
gerade ausheckt? Denn wenn Fable 5.5
relativ bald veröffentlicht wird, wird
das definitiv das gesamte KI-Rennen
verändern. Wenn ihr die besten
KI-Tools, Workflows und Drops vor allen
anderen haben wollt, abonniert meinen
kostenlosen Newsletter mit dem Link in
der Beschreibung unten, der völlig
kostenlos ist. Anthropic hat offiziell
Sonnet 5.5 veröffentlicht, das zweite
Modell der Claude 5.5-Familie. Und
heute werden wir uns ein paar
verschiedene Tests ansehen, die wir
durchführen werden. Das ist etwas, das
wir in diesem KI-News-Video tun werden.
Und wenn ihr natürlich zu den
nächsten Abschnitten springen wollt,
könnt ihr das auch tun. Aber Sonnet
5.5 ist ein ziemlich großes Upgrade
gegenüber Sonnet 5. Wir alle wissen,
dass Sonnet 5 eine Art Katastrophe war,
und wir alle wissen, dass der Sprung
mit diesem Modell in den Benchmarks von
Anthropic ziemlich groß ist. Sonnet
5.5 ist in Bezug auf das Modell selbst
ziemlich gewaltig. Laut Anthropic ist
es mehr als 30%schneller und kann bis
zu 30%weniger pro Aufgabe kosten,
hauptsächlich durch die Verwendung von
weniger Token und Gesamtkosten. Ehrlich
gesagt, basierend auf dem, was ich
bisher gesehen habe, ist es ziemlich
tokenlastig und wirklich teuer, wenn
man High Reasoning verwendet. Es ist
irgendwie verrückt, dass dies das
mittelgroße Modell von Anthropic sein
soll, denn seine Leistung kommt dem
Stand der Technik bereits sehr nahe.
Sonnet 5.5 verbessert sich im Grunde
genommen auf ganzer Linie, mit einigen
absolut massiven Zuwächsen bei
Codierungs-und Agentenaufgaben, wo es
sogar das Sonnet 5 sowie das Opus 5.5
auf Terminal Bench 4 schlägt, was
schon irgendwie verblüffend ist. Und
bei alltäglichen Aufgaben, der
Behebung von Fehlern und der Erstellung
ausgefeilter Dokumente, Folien und
Tabellenkalkulationen kommt es Opus 5.5
wirklich sehr nahe. Anthropic
positioniert dieses Modell also als
schneller, kostengünstiger und als
Ergänzung zu Opus 5.5, weshalb ich
sage, dass es ein großartiger
Alltagsbegleiter sein könnte. Sonnet
5.5 hat ein Kontextfenster von 1
Million Token. Die maximale Ausgabe ist
mit 128.000 Token angegeben und der
Eingabepreis ist mit 2 USD pro 1
Million Eingabetoken und 10 USD pro 1
Million Ausgabetoken angegeben. Auf der
World of AI Benchmark und der Bob
Conan-Plattform, zu der ich unten in
der Beschreibung einen Link hinterlasse
, haben wir dieses Modell rigoros
getestet und sind zu dem Schluss
gekommen, dass dieses Modell derzeit
auf Platz 3 der Gesamtwertung der
Rangliste steht und GPT-6 Soul
übertrifft, was irgendwie verrückt
ist. Und ehrlich gesagt werden die
Ergebnisse, die Sie in diesem Video
sehen werden, wirklich zeigen, warum es
so weit oben steht. Leute, dies ist der
beste Weg für euch, jedes Modell zu
testen und Einblicke zu erhalten, was
ihr tun könnt und wie ihr diese
Plattform im Wesentlichen nutzen könnt
, um mit jedem KI-Modell zu beginnen.
Ich hinterlasse also unten in der
Beschreibung einen Link dazu. Ihr
könnt sogar auf meine
Prompt-Bibliothek zugreifen, daher
empfehle ich euch dringend, sie über
die Links unten in der Beschreibung
auszuprobieren. Sonnet 5.5 erreicht
beim Intelligence Index von Artificial
Analysis ebenfalls einen Wert von 56
und liegt damit nur zwei Punkte hinter
Opus 5.5 Max und 18 Punkte über Sonnet
5. Das ist ein ziemlich großer Sprung.
Das größte Problem, das mir bei
meinen eigenen Eingabeaufforderungen
und Tests jedoch aufgefallen ist, ist
die Token-Effizienz. Bei maximalem
Aufwand verbraucht Sonnet 5.5 etwa 100
Token pro Aufgabe. Das ist der höchste
Wert, den Artificial Analysis je
gemessen hat, und außerdem etwa das
Siebenfache von GPT-6 Astra bei
maximalem Aufwand. Das ist schon
verrückt. Aber obwohl es sich um das
mittelgroße Modell von Anthropic
handelt, schlägt es Opus 5.5 und GPT-6
Astra beim Terminal Bench 4 mit 64%
gegenüber 60%und kommt Opus bei
mehreren Agenten-und
Wissensarbeits-Benchmarks sehr nahe.
Ich möchte, dass Sie sich das ansehen.
Ich habe Claude Sonnet 5.5 in Claude
Code mit aktiviertem Ultra-Modus
gebeten, in 3 Tagen einen
vollständigen Call of Duty
Zombies-Klon zu erstellen. Und das
alles wurde mit einer einzigen
Aufforderung erledigt, Leute. Ich habe
gesagt, dass es keine Fragen stellen
und es einfach abschicken soll. Und das
ist die Qualität. Da kommen diese
Zombies auf mich zu. Und dieses Mal
spiele ich das Spiel nicht wirklich mit
, denn erinnert ihr euch, was letztes
Mal passiert ist? Ich habe es dann doch
gespielt und vergessen, die Aufnahme zu
beenden. Ich habe einfach
weitergespielt und im Grunde genommen
etwa 5 Minuten eurer Zeit während des
Videos verbraucht. Nur ich, der die
Simulation gespielt hat, die das Kabel
oder Opus 5.5 generiert hat. Aber in
diesem Fall könnt ihr sehen, dass
Sonnet 5.5 alle tatsächlichen Elemente
des Originalspiels mitgeliefert hat.
Ihr könnt die vernagelten Fenster
sehen, die von den Zombies
auseinandergerissen werden. Ihr könnt
die Barrieren wieder aufbauen. Ihr habt
eine Überraschungskiste mit einem
Teddybären, der sie bewegen kann. Ihr
habt vier Vorteile. Ihr habt
Pack-a-Punch, was ein echtes Feature
des Originalspiels ist. Und dann habt
ihr noch all diese coolen kleinen Dinge
wie die verschiedenen Waffenarten, die
ihr kaufen könnt, sowie das Erkunden
verschiedener Räume. Insgesamt bin ich
einfach nur verblüfft, wie gut das
Tool alles texturieren konnte. Es hat
auch all die kleinen Details
hinzugefügt, die man bei einem
mittelgroßen Modell wie dem
Sonnet-Output wirklich nicht erwarten
würde. Die Frontend-Fähigkeiten
scheinen bislang einzigartig zu sein,
und es hat seinen eigenen
Designgeschmack wie das Opus 5.5.
Insgesamt sieht es so aus, als würde
es bei verschiedenen Aufgaben recht gut
funktionieren, denn hier haben wir es
gebeten, eine Nvidia-GPU-Landingpage zu
erstellen. Eines fällt mir sofort auf:
Es hat die 3 D-GPU hervorragend
erstellt, wozu die meisten hochmodernen
Modelle in der Lage sind. Aber man
sieht auch die Reflexion, die es
generiert hat, das ist der Wahnsinn.
Man hat eine elegante kleine
Landingpage, die alle anderen Elemente
präsentiert. Ja, das Diagramm.
Insgesamt gefallen mir einfach die
dynamischen Bewegungen und die coolen
Funktionen und der Designgeschmack, den
es dieser Landingpage verliehen hat.
Hier ist ein 360-Grad-Produktviewer,
der wirklich beeindruckend ist. Dies
ist eine Premium-Ausgabe, die vom Cloud
Sonnet 5.5 generiert wurde. Hier haben
Sie die Möglichkeit, alle
verschiedenen Farben zu ändern. Ich
bin wirklich begeistert, dass jede
einzelne Funktion dieser Landingpage
oder dieses Viewers genau auf der
Grundlage unserer Vorgaben funktioniert
. Das ist wirklich unglaublich, denn
hier haben wir Sonnet 5.5 angewiesen,
die Skyline von New York City zu
erstellen. Wir haben ihm gesagt, dass
es mindestens 2.000 Zeilen haben soll,
kein Schummeln mit Auffüllung. Das ist
der Detailgrad, den ich wirklich nicht
von Sonnet erwartet hätte. Sie sehen,
dass Sie bei der Skyline verschiedene
Tageszeiten haben, zu denen Sie
wechseln können. Sie haben coole
kleine Elemente wie verschiedene
Details, die wir vom Modell nicht
wirklich erwartet hätten, wie z. B.
die Segelboote. Sie haben sogar die
Reflexionen der Wolkenkratzer sowie
viele andere Dinge wie einen
Hubschrauber, der in die
entgegengesetzte Richtung fliegt.
Trotzdem haben Sie diese coolen kleinen
Leute, die herumlaufen oder so animiert
sind, dass sie auf seltsame Weise
laufen. Insgesamt liebe ich einfach die
Qualität und die Tiefe, die es mit
dieser spezifischen Ausgabe generieren
konnte. Das ist wirklich schön zu
sehen. Die Tageszeit scheint
tatsächlich nicht zu funktionieren,
was der einzige Nachteil ist. Das muss
der beste und genaueste Minecraft-Klon
sein, den ich je von einem KI-Modell
gesehen habe. Das sind Ergebnisse, die
mit Sonic 5.5 erzielt wurden, und sie
sind wirklich beeindruckend. Es gibt
Höhlengenerationen, es gibt Texturen
für alle verschiedenen Blöcke wie im
ursprünglichen Sandbox-Spiel, und
alles scheint perfekt zu funktionieren,
angefangen von der Wasserphysik,
insbesondere der Wassereimermechanik,
und das Höhlensystem ist
wahrscheinlich das Beste. Es gibt Erze,
und es werden sogar Mobs in diesen
verschiedenen Höhlensystemen generiert
, wie im eigentlichen Spiel, was
verrückt ist, sogar Fackeln. Wir
kommen also an einen Punkt, an dem
diese Eingabeaufforderung fast bis ins
kleinste Detail perfektioniert ist, was
irgendwie verrückt ist. Es ist einfach
unglaublich, dass wir an einen Punkt
gelangen, an dem diese KI-Modelle
solche Spiele auf so unglaubliche Weise
klonen können. Wenn man nun Sonic 5.5
mit hoher Denkleistung auf X mit GPT-6
Soul oder sogar Astra mit höherer
Argumentation vergleicht, erhält man
im Grunde ähnliche Ergebnisse und
übertrifft in vielen Fällen sogar
Soul. Aber das Verrückte ist, dass man
diese verrückten Ergebnisse mit
praktisch denselben identischen
API-Preisen erhält. Hier ist ein
Vergleich von Sonic 5.5 mit dem GPT-6
Astra, wobei beide mit genau derselben
Eingabeaufforderung auf hoher
Argumentation auf X getestet wurden.
Astra war in etwa 15 Minuten fertig und
kostete mit dieser Ausgabe 16 US-Dollar
, während es mit Sonic etwa 25 Minuten
dauerte, aber nur 3 US-Dollar kostete.
Und wenn man die endgültigen Artefakte
tatsächlich vergleicht, ist der
Unterschied ziemlich deutlich. Die
Ergebnisse von Sonnet sehen deutlich
besser aus, obwohl sie fast fünfmal
weniger kosten. Und das kann man
natürlich anhand all dieser kleinen
Effekte erkennen, die von dieser
Landingpage ausgehen. Ein weiterer
Benchmark, bei dem Sonnet 5.5 mit Opus
5.5 und GPT Astra verglichen wurde, und
zwar bei hohem Aufwand X unter
Verwendung der exakt gleichen
Eingabeaufforderung wie bei den anderen
Modellen. Die Gesamtergebnisse können
nicht ganz mit Opus 5.5 mithalten. Man
kann deutlich erkennen, dass es
definitiv einen Unterschied gibt, aber
die Farbqualität sieht beim Sonnet 5.5
extrem gut aus. Der Kontrast ist dort
definitiv gut. Es dauerte etwa 1 Stunde
und 54 Minuten und kostete 7,73 $. Es
ist also definitiv ziemlich langsam bei
dieser Aufgabe und bei maximalem
Aufwand sehen die Ergebnisse definitiv
besser aus, aber es gibt offensichtlich
einen großen Kompromiss. Es verbraucht
offensichtlich viele Token, was
wahrscheinlich einer der wenigen
Nachteile des Sonnet-Modells bisher ist
. Mein Fazit zum Sonnet 5.5 ist also,
dass es sich um ein bemerkenswertes
mittelgroßes Modell handelt, das sich
nicht wirklich wie ein mittelgroßes
Modell anfühlt. Es ist ein riesiger
Sprung gegenüber dem Sonnet 5. Es
läuft 30%schneller und kostet bei den
meisten Aufgaben bis zu 30%weniger. Es
ist praktisch identisch mit Opus 5.5,
liegt nur in einigen verschiedenen
Bereichen etwas zurück. Für mich ist
es eher grenzwertig. Natürlich muss
ich es noch in mehreren Bereichen
weiter testen, um diese Behauptung
tatsächlich zu bestätigen, aber
insgesamt ist es ein wirklich, wirklich
schönes Modell und etwas, das sich
hervorragend als täglicher Begleiter
auf niedrigeren Denkebenen eignet.
Preislich ist es natürlich nicht das
Beste, aber es ist immer noch relevant
und günstig. Wenn euch dieses Video
gefällt und ihr den Kanal
unterstützen möchtet, könnt ihr
über die unten stehende Option „
Super Thanks“ für meinen Kanal
spenden. Oder ihr schließt euch
unserem privaten Discord an, wo ihr
monatlich kostenlos auf mehrere
Abonnements für verschiedene KI-Tools
zugreifen könnt, sowie auf tägliche
KI-News und exklusive Inhalte und
vieles mehr. Aber was die Zukunft
betrifft, haben wir ziemlich düstere
Neuigkeiten von OpenAI, denn GPT-6.1
Astra, das um den Dev Day herum
erscheinen sollte, wurde offiziell
verschoben. Laut Wall Street Journal
bereitete OpenAI GPT-6.1 Astra für
einen Start im Oktober vor. Interne
Tests ergaben jedoch, dass es die
Sicherheits-und Abstimmungsstandards
des Unternehmens nicht erfüllte. Das
Verrückte daran ist, dass das Modell
offenbar besser in der Lage war,
schwierige Aufgaben ohne menschliche
Hilfe durchgängig zu erledigen, und
Probleme wie Modellträgheit
verbesserte. Allerdings zeigte es auch
einige irreführende Verhaltensweisen,
die seine Vorgänger nicht hatten, und
berichtete manchmal ungenau, was es
getan hatte, und überschritt seinen
zulässigen Rahmen, einschließlich des
Versuchs, externe Tools zu verwenden,
wenn dies nicht vorgesehen war. Stimmt
das nun? Ich weiß es nicht, aber das
Nichteinhalten von Sicherheitsstandards
ist eine sehr höfliche Art, das Rennen
um ein Modell tatsächlich zu verlieren
, und meiner Meinung nach ist dies, wie
ich zu Beginn des Videos erwähnt habe,
möglicherweise eine Möglichkeit für
sie, die Einführung ihres Modells zu
verzögern, da sie nicht dieselben
Standards wie Anthropic erfüllen. Aber
egal, ich weiß wirklich nicht, was sie
jetzt am Dev Day vorhaben. Ich weiß,
dass es noch viele weitere Leaks gibt,
über die wir bald sprechen werden,
aber das ist schon ein harter Schlag,
denn das sollte einer der großen
Launches beim Dev Day sein. Aber wir
wissen mit Sicherheit, dass sie alle
ihre Always-On-Assistenten vorstellen
werden, über die wir gesprochen haben,
und ich kann euch nur wärmstens
empfehlen, euch das Video dazu
anzusehen, falls ihr das noch nicht
getan habt. Eine weitere Sache, die sie
bestätigt haben, sind die mehr als 20
Launches. Wir wissen nicht, was das
für Launches sein werden, aber ich
vermute ein paar Dinge. Eine der
wichtigsten Neuerungen ist, dass OpenAI
einen größeren Teil seiner Plattform
direkt in Codex einbringt. Dadurch
können Entwickler Plugins, Agenten und
Apps direkt über einen speziellen
Dev-Day erstellen. Die Sessions selbst
sind aber noch interessanter, denn es
gibt ein Codex-Game-Studio, in dem
Entwickler buchstäblich Spiele
entwickeln, die Codex herausfordern
sollen. Außerdem wird in einer Session
ein interner OpenAI-Agent enthüllt,
der offenbar mehr als tausend Stunden
lang lief und dabei Ziele, Subagenten
und persistente Pläne verwendete, um
kontinuierlich Fehler zu untersuchen
und eine große Codebasis zu reparieren
. Außerdem gibt es noch Codex has left
laptop, das sich darauf konzentriert,
dass Codex über einzelne
Codierungsaufgaben hinausgeht und
stattdessen autonom ganze Probleme und
Ziele bearbeitet. Und die
wahrscheinlich interessanteste Sitzung
davon ist das Thema „Was kommt nach
den Schleifen?“. In dieser Sitzung
wird OpenAI den Wandel von einfachen
Agentenschleifen hin zu mehreren
zusammenarbeitenden Agenten untersuchen
und wie die nächste Generation von
Agentenarchitekturen aussehen wird.
Jetzt haben wir möglicherweise einen
der bisher größten Dev-Day-Leaks, und
hier bereitet OpenAI Berichten zufolge
etwas namens Dots vor. Im Wesentlichen
antwortet es auf seine autonomen
KI-Begleiter wie Meta Mews und Crocbot.
Der größte Unterschied besteht jedoch
darin, dass Dot anscheinend so
konzipiert ist, dass es tatsächlich
selbstständig funktioniert. Dein Dot
kann anscheinend laufende Aufgaben
ausführen, dich benachrichtigen, wenn
die Recherche tatsächlich
abgeschlossen ist, entscheiden, wann er
deine Genehmigung benötigt, und
benutzerdefinierte Regeln befolgen, die
steuern, was er tun kann und was nicht.
Noch verrückter ist, dass jeder Dot
tatsächlich auf seinen eigenen
virtuellen Computer zugreifen könnte,
der als Computer deines eigenen Dots
bezeichnet wird, sodass der Agent
tatsächlich mit Websites interagieren
und Aufgaben erledigen kann. Es gibt
auch Hinweise darauf, dass ChatGPT
heimlich Passwörter speichern könnte,
sodass sich diese Agenten in deinem
Namen über den Browser bei Webseiten
anmelden können. Und anscheinend wird
es für Dots auch eine Reihe von 3
D-Anpassungsoptionen geben. Wenn das
alles morgen startet, könnte das Open
AIs bisher größter Schritt in
Richtung eines Always-On-Assistenten
sein. Aber mir fallen spontan ein, was
demnächst erscheinen könnte: ihr
Always-On-Assistent wie Grok Bot, der
500-Dollar-Ax-Plan, sogar Aion, falls
das zählt. Dann gibt es noch GPT-6.1
Soul, das erscheinen könnte, aber da
bin ich mir noch nicht so sicher. Und
natürlich das Codex-Update, über das
wir gesprochen haben. Es gibt auch ein
paar kleine Features in Codex, aber das
sind nur ein paar Dinge, über die ich
spekulieren kann. Ax und Anthropic,
weil sie einen neuen Workflow
eingeführt haben, bei dem Claude dir
beim Erstellen von Bewertungen helfen
kann, gegen die er dann antritt. Im
Grunde kann Claude Code dir dabei
helfen, Evaluierungen für deine
Anwendung zu entwerfen, Schwachstellen
zu identifizieren und Verbesserungen
vorzunehmen. Anschließend können
diese Änderungen wiederholt anhand der
Evaluierungen getestet werden, um die
Anwendung im Laufe der Zeit iterativ zu
verbessern. Dies könnte äußerst
nützlich für Entwickler sein, die
versuchen, ihre Agenten und
KI-Anwendungen systematisch zu
verbessern, anstatt sich nur auf
Stimmungen zu verlassen und dann zu
sehen, ob sich tatsächlich etwas
verbessert hat. Wenn wir uns den
chinesischen KI-Laboren zuwenden, sieht
es so aus, als würde das Moonshot
AI-Team Kimi K 3.1 auf den Markt
bringen. Das Modell befindet sich nun
in der Testphase. Berichten zufolge
wurde das Modell heute in Kimis
Backend-Modellregistrierung mit dem
Kimi K-1-Slug entdeckt und wurde sogar
im API-Katalog gefunden. Das bedeutet
natürlich nicht, dass K 3.1 sehr bald
auf den Markt kommen wird, aber es ist
etwas, das uns einen kleinen
Vorgeschmack darauf gegeben hat, wozu
dieses Open-Source-Flaggschiffmodell in
der Lage ist. Es hat offenbar 2,8
Billionen Parameter und auch die
Preisgestaltung wurde tatsächlich
geleakt. Und wir haben sogar DeepSeek,
die an der Version 4.1 Pro arbeiten,
die möglicherweise nur noch Tage
entfernt ist, denn es gab einen
Mitarbeiter, der an der Deep
Seek-Oberfläche arbeitet, und er hat
Berichten zufolge den Nutzern in einer
Beta-Gruppe mitgeteilt, dass die
offizielle Desktop-Version am Montag
oder Dienstag vor dem chinesischen
Nationalfeiertag erscheinen wird.
Interessant ist jedoch, dass Deep Seek
auch angekündigt hat, dass die Version
4.1 Pro zusammen mit der offiziellen
Version der Deep Seek-Oberfläche auf
den Markt kommen wird. Wenn dieser
Zeitplan also noch eingehalten wird,
wird wahrscheinlich auch die Deep
Seek-Version 4.1 Pro live gehen. Dann
haben wir noch Alibaba. Was braut sich
hinter den Kulissen zusammen? Und wir
haben kürzlich die Modellfamilie für
Qwen 4.0 auf der Aspara-Konferenz
gesehen. Aber jetzt haben wir dieses
neue mysteriöse Qwen-Vorschaumodell
mit dem Codenamen Qwen Latest Series
Invite 2609, das ist das Datum, und die
Evaluierungen laufen bis zum 30.
September. Es gibt keine Bestätigung,
welche Modelle tatsächlich getestet
werden, aber es besteht die
Möglichkeit, dass es sich um einen
frühen Blick auf das Qwen-4-Modell
handelt. Im Baidu-Forum gibt es
tatsächlich ein paar verschiedene
Tests für das Qwen-4-Modell, die in
einer geschlossenen Betaphase
durchgeführt wurden. Hier hat es sich
über mehrere Generationen hinweg
extrem gut geschlagen, insbesondere mit
Vox Art. Das sieht man bei dieser
Pagoda. Man sieht auch die Qualität
dieser Generationen, und es zeigt
einfach, wie unglaublich dieses Modell
sein wird. Und ich bin wahnsinnig
gespannt auf das lokale Modell, das das
27-Milliarden-Parameter-Modell für die
Qwen-4-Modellreihe sein wird, mit dem
wir lokal praktisch hochmoderne
Ergebnisse erhalten werden, was der
Wahnsinn sein wird. Zu guter Letzt gibt
es noch eine Firma namens Skil-ed AI,
und das ist ein Roboter, der Fußball
spielt, Leute. Football, wie auch immer
ihr es nennen wollt. Aber ich kann euch
mit Sicherheit sagen, dass es in ein
paar Jahren einen Roboter geben wird,
der uns alle tunneln wird, was uns
natürlich zum Weinen bringen wird,
aber das ist einfach nur Wahnsinn. Wir
haben hier einen Roboter, der durch
Eigeninitiative gelernt hat, Fußball
zu spielen, und nicht durch manuelle
Programmierung jeder Bewegung. Er hat
sich selbst in einer virtuellen
Umgebung trainiert, die etwa 140 Jahren
ununterbrochenem Fußballspiel
entspricht. Er hat unentwegt gegen sich
selbst gespielt, durch Versuch und
Irrtum gelernt und konnte schließlich
tatsächlich Fußball spielen. Dabei
wird er sogar besser als die Menschen,
die ihr hier seht. Ich will nicht
gemein sein, aber das Ergebnis ist,
dass sich der Roboter tatsächlich
bewegen, verteidigen, angreifen und
seine Strategie auf dem Spielfeld
anpassen kann. Ein weiteres verrücktes
Beispiel ist, wie weit Reinforcement
Learning und Simulation mittlerweile
sogar die Robotik vorantreiben. Aber
das war's im Grunde genommen auch schon
mit dem heutigen Video. Das ist ein
Video, für das ich wirklich sehr, sehr
lange gebraucht habe. Es würde mir
also sehr viel bedeuten, wenn ihr
diesem Video ein „Gefällt mir“
gebt, den Kanal abonniert und die
Benachrichtigungen aktiviert, damit ihr
über alle Neuigkeiten in der Welt der
KI auf dem Laufenden bleibt. Ich hoffe,
euch hat dieses Video gefallen und ihr
konntet etwas Wertvolles daraus lernen.
Ich werde all diese Links unten in der
Beschreibung hinterlassen, wie die
World of AI School Community, wie
unsere World of AI Vibe Coding Platform
und Benchmark. Schaut euch den zweiten
Kanal an, abonniert unseren Newsletter,
folgt uns auf Discord, folgt mir auf
Twitter und zu guter Letzt: Abonniert
unbedingt unseren Kanal, aktiviert die
Benachrichtigungsglocke, liked dieses
Video und schaut euch bitte auch unsere
vorherigen Videos an, damit ihr über
die aktuellsten KI-News auf dem
Laufenden bleibt. Aber in diesem Sinne,
Leute, habt einen wunderschönen Tag,
verbreitet Positivität und ich sehe
euch ganz bald wieder. Peace out, Fuzz.